I want to talk about Arlington what
happened oh yeah the artwork there but
there was a drama that happened there no
but we spoke a little bit about it so
let's let's hear it I'm also gonna
exempt myself in this conversation be
easy about you are because you're gonna
be there in two weeks yeah because I I'm
gonna go play there and I like it and I
don't know I don't know what this is so
I'm saying this for this is I'm
pre-empting this I don't know this
whatever this is I shouldn't say it that
oh yeah you should go say you
experienced it yeah you're experienced
you know what I think okay I want to say
this okay is that um I love this club
have you played this one before I had
one time yeah yeah I absolutely [ __ ]
love it yeah Arlington dress the reason
why I love it is because the people that
run in to own it the owner of the club
whenever I'm in town she meets me at
breakfast and we hug I know her daughter
and it's she I feel at home we're good
people they really are great people and
she's great yeah and um I have no
problem with the manager but we had a
[ __ ] falling-out
what happened well what happened was
Saturday night does the owner know about
this no okay good go ahead Friday night
we I get a tweet from this young girl
and she's I got one too I saw it oh yeah
yeah I got it she tweeted both of you
guys she basically said listen I I drew
I'm a tiger belly fan I drove for hours
what yeah um I had a peter by nine
because I guess if you're under 21 yes
you're 49 I can't get in yeah because
they let it they have a cutoff for under
20 I'm on my way into the club because I
got there at 8:30 she was there at 8:30
you saw her we made eye contact and so I
think she tried to make a case for it
because she was like I belong right and
they couldn't they would didn't let her
in because she's mine yeah which is not
her fault sure right so he just grew up
poor girl drove for hours and couldn't
get in and so we basically said there's
nothing we can do but if you wait you
can hang out with us afterwards
it's cool it's a great gift very cool
yeah so she's it's really cold there so
she sat in a car with her boyfriend oh
my god Ryder in three hours we brought
her in through the back for about an
hour and we talked about horses her life
she was just a dope chick dope chick but
I got to the point where I was like can
we hire her no we want her on the pot
yes so interest she's so interesting
she's like a young black chick with this
Nigerian kind of Gary oh right she had
like this ad is like she was a black but
black he was dope as [ __ ] dope as [ __ ]
dope she was she was like she's like oh
my god this is like so worth it you know
and I go oh cool I'm glad you feel that
way I go she goes can we get a photo
before I go and I go yeah but let's not
doing in here it's dim let's go out yeah
into the lobby no one else left in the
club they already was gone yes gaff is
gone yeah also worth noting
besides comedy shows that club operates
as a cinema it's a movie theater it's a
movie yeah I've been there yeah all ages
movie theater right it's a local town
movie theater yeah it's not only that
it's eclectic the place it's like you
know that they have weird shows there
it's a place for art it's an artist
community minutes great great but what
do you want an over Club all day that's
not what it is okay so we go out into
the lobby and um all of a sudden we run
into the manager and he just goes get
the hell out I told you guys earlier
ma'am and you're in get out to her yeah
and she and he saw that you were with
them yeah yeah they go whoa dude calm
down
you guys know I'm not talking to you I'm
talking to them get out she was there
with her phone like yeah like and I go
don't talk to be it that way I don't
know like I said Bobby speak speak at
all he's like no out get out and at this
point I take the
you and I well I could see I looked at
Carla's face and she has a thing when
her eyes get crossed and the blood just
leaves her face her age yet her rage is
about to you know because I've been in
rage moments we've yelled at people
before together it's not a good day and
it was happening before this goes bad
that's what her and I rage out it's the
greatest thing in the world as a duo we
point fingers we rip their physical
their emotional state their spiritual
state we attack every angle and they
want to kill themselves and we had just
this amazing hour with these two kids a
beautiful hour yeah and then now tainted
by the fact that this guy was just
screaming for no [ __ ] reason just
being power trippy and so was like you
know what guys let's just walk out I'd
let Bobby take you think he had a
negative interaction with him before the
show no you don't think it was like they
fought with him prior baby III I wonder
why that's why so much attitude not only
that though I don't care because I gave
then when they left I started talking
and basically I said this and I might
have this could be wrong but this is the
right thing mmm and this is gonna sound
really [ __ ] up
I think no no I'm right this is what I
believe yeah I go listen in LA I've seen
big comics like chappal mmm coming with
somebody with no ID Yeah right
they could be 21 they might not be I
don't know but is anyone gonna ask no no
no if they're in the club and you see
two kids that look like underage that's
Chris Rock's friends or whoever he walks
in there with them do we say no to
something no no right you wouldn't say
[ __ ] in fact even it could be even you
know even lower level than that like
somebody like um Greg Fitzsimmons sure
great comic friend even if Greg's in
there with somebody I'm not gonna say
anything
that's great Fitzsimmons yeah what'd you
write why would I why here's the reason
why is because this is a comedy club and
what they sell is comics yeah we are the
product yep right you don't [ __ ] with
that and so what and so you leave I say
that to him and this guy and he's like
I'd know he's kept using no
no I don't know he said no no no you're
not dude this is my club and I was kind
of like oh okay
what night was this Friday night and he
was basically like this Friday Saturday
oh yeah like you don't talk to my fans
in that way yeah this person it's not
yeah it's not even just a fan dude it's
a tiger belly fan more important no I
want to see something right now tiger
belly fans come out for hours
they drive for hours I know they wear
the shirts well right let me let me let
me back it up but the thing that a lot
of these and I'm not I don't have
anything to do with this case but the
thing that a lot of people forget in the
world of comedy running clubs and all
that stuff is at the end of the day
these people that like go so deep to
come see you
the real fans yeah are the most
important yeah people that just go to
shows to just grab a night out I
appreciate those humans as well but it's
different it's different when someone's
like I'm a fan I love you I came just
for you yeah they need to understand it
that's the only way for this business to
keep going yeah we're having a boom and
everyone loves going to comedy shows but
I got to tell you it's not gonna [ __ ]
last forever you know who's gonna be
around the [ __ ] fans yeah
the people that just go to get a [ __ ]
drink and have a night off they're not
gonna [ __ ] be there they leave they
go ah we could go see him or no the fans
will always be there they need to know
that that's an important structure to
keep us alive but them and us but
they're not just fans I have a feeling
for them as well well there's some
saying but I mean it's like community
there's so many years where I fell like
my career was over
you still feel that today still there is
parts of me that I know right and you
feel the same way everyone feels that
way today when I'm done with this I'm
gonna jump I know but oddly enough it's
these fans that make me go all right I'm
gonna keep going to worth it it's worth
it totally because they're the nurses
they're the sign of hope
yeah right there are the ones that are
like giving me the money to pay rent or
buy food to live and keep doing write
what you think gives me that fuel and
energy so when he yelled at these young
kids as a trigger right it [ __ ] rage
it enraged me but then again I know that
I've been in trouble before clubs for
like sticking up for myself and I've
never been back there happens like
you're not wrong I understand that they
also think that you later found out that
he hadn't slept in like 35 hours he was
having a bad day like all you have did
you guys reconciled no in fact the next
night so nothing was what has happened I
didn't go to the Saturday show you see
boycotted Saturday yeah well I just
didn't want to be there for the awkward
you know run-in sweaty hands yeah but
what happened was coming no the night
before that happened please to ask me a
favor he goes oh you we our club has a
podcast and you did it he goes can you
do it tomorrow night
so I said oh yeah for sure no before
everything happened then the thing
happened and then that night I'm laying
in bed because you said yes cuz I said
yes but you could have just said no I I
was going to but then what happened was
the to two people that are doing the
podcast or a local guy or comics that
one of them was open before and the
other girl I knew in LA right so then
they pretend they brought him with their
equipment that's even harder he walks
him with them with equipment and I'm
like like that and I did it and then at
the end you got age at the end he said
hey sorry about yesterday man he said
yeah what you sorry about it and I go my
only response was I'll get over it one
day that's yeah that's honest yeah What
did he say there's anything no walked
away he gave me the check here's the
money yeah
[Music]